[Musique]
cette première pierre posée est la
première de la future maison
départementale située à petite île
un bâtiment qui rassemblera plusieurs
services départementaux comme
l'insertion l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et les services de pmi une maison
départementale qui s'intègre dans un
projet de mixité et de développement du
territoire
nous avons une opération mixte qui va
comprendre 80 logements dont 45
logements réservés aux personnes âgées
nous aurons également des services
notamment la maison départementale 6 à
petite île
nous aurons des locaux d'activités et
parmi ces locaux il y aura aussi une
crèche une crèche qui va aussi recevoir
des enfants handicapés
cette 14e maisons départementales
fonctionnera avec un effectif de dix
neuf agents ce guichet unique permettra
de mieux accompagner et orienter les
publics
une modernisation de l'offre des
services ainsi qu'un cadre de travail
plus opérationnelles et fonctionnelles
pour les agents travaillent à l'ensemble
de nos agents
quel que soit l'endroit du territoire de
la réunion au il se trouve à petit ils
ce sont 19 agents qui vont avoir de
meilleures conditions de travail une
fois que le robot est livrée et donc
c'est ce que nous voulons essayer à
petite île mais aussi sur l'ensemble de
la réunion
la maison départementale de la résidence
bois de jolis coeurs ouvrira ses portes
en juillet 2021
[Musique]